bonsoir je râle d'olivier merci de
répondre à nos questions vous êtes
spécialiste des états unis comment
est-ce que vous interprétez le dernier
discours de donald trump donald trump
qui s'est envolé vers la floride sur my
way est ce que c'est un ultime pied de
nez
égouttez bonsoir merci votre invitation
j'ai trouvé que c'était un excellent
discours et j'ai trouvé que c'est le
discours qu'il aurait dû faire le 6 le 6
janvier devant le capitole plutôt que
celui qu'il a fait et qui a provoqué les
tous les incidents que nous avons pu
observer et qu'ils ont pour moi ruiner
la fin de son mandat je considère que
donald trump depuis 24 heures peut-être
48 heures c'est un nouveau comporter
comme un président est comme un
président dont dont ses supporters
peuvent être fiers alors qu'il y a eu
une période à la fin du cycle électoral
américain
justement à la proche du 6 janvier où il
s'est laissé je dirais dominé par ses
propres démons et il n'a pas été en
mesure d'imaginer les conséquences de
ses actes je pense qu'en effet
l'envahissement du capitole a été un
événement catastrophique parce que c'est
un événement qui restera comme l'image
du mandat de donald trump
alors qu'il y avait eu avant d'autres
éléments beaucoup plus positif est
beaucoup plus en mesure de symboliser ce
qu'avait été véritablement sa présidence
donc là il s'est ressaisi il a accepté
un défaut de reconnaître le résultat de
l'élection il a accepté de quitter la
maison blanche et une transition je
n'irai pacifique du pouvoir
je regrette personnellement qu'il ne
soit pas en ce moment au capitole pour
être présent je dirais sur les photos
qui marqueront cet événement qu'il soit
une chance pour une histoire là comme
s'était bonne chance à à joe biden et au
capitole justement sont arrivés en
l'équipe de george deubeuliou bouche
couple obama couple clinton mais
évidemment le couple trump
mais lanières et donald de l'intérieur
d'ici quelques instants du côté de la
flore eater michael oenning
voilà mais mais mais cette cette image
cette image pour moi va être terrible
d'une certaine façon parce qu'on verra
les présidents qui ont précédé byden on
verra obama on verra clinton on verra
george w bush et il n'y aura pas trump
or depuis quatre ans les démocrates nous
disent trump est un président illégitime
et donc s'il est absent sur la photo je
suis désolé de considérer ça un petit
peu comme regarder leurs politiques pour
lui tant de l'union soviétique
oui c'est évident qui à 84 me enfin il
ya 74 millions d'américains qui ont voté
pour lui mais pour l'histoire il aurait
été pour moi important qu'ils soient
présents aujourd'hui c'est à dire qu'il
accepte les conséquences de ce qui
s'était passé le 3 novembre et au tour
de cette élection
hmm hmm je dirais une certaine façon
sans considérer qu'elle avait été
totalement je dirai juste dans
l'ensemble de son déroulement mais
qu'ils acceptent le processus et qu'il
s'inscrive qu'il s'inscrit dans la
passation de pouvoir il a l'intention de
rester en politique il a l'intention de
revenir dans quatre ans il a dit à ses
supporters hier notre mouvement ne fait
que commencer c'est une phrase très
positive était une phrase chargé
d'espoir mais j'estime qu'il ya eu cet
incident du 6 janvier qui a été très mal
géré très mal méprisés et qui
malheureusement sera exploité par ses
adversaires par ses détracteurs et ça
risque d'être un petit peu l'image qui
restera et c'est très dommage on voit
des images en direct un de cette
cérémonie particulière à plus d'un titre
en gérald son public pandémie oblige
avec des soldats de la garde nationale
après donc les fameuses événements du 6
janvier dernier 25 mille soldats
déployés dans la capitale
ce 20 janvier 2021 il restera dans les
annales ah oui absolument
c'est une c'est une transition c'est une
passation de pouvoirs que que je n'ai
jamais que je n'ai jamais connu c'est
pas comme ça que c'est supposé se passer
c'est à dire que
normalement la transition c'est un
événement festif
c'est un événement politique où on
célèbre la démocratie on célèbre le
passage de témoin
et même si la personne à qui on le passe
n'est pas forcément de son corps
idéologique ou de son parti on accepte
que ça fait partie de la vie politique
parce qu'on sait très bien que l'on
travaille chacun à sa façon à l'intérêt
du pays
et là on a un président qui un baril
donnent qui a fait campagne
véritablement je dirais par défaut on
est presque dans le prolongement de la
campagne parce qu'abidal n'a pas fait de
grands meetings comme l'a fait donald
trump
là où se présentaient brydon y avait
très peu de public
il y avait une distanciation on prenait
prétexte de la pandémie
mais en vérité il y avait peut-être un
manque d'enthousiasmé pour bayonne
et là on a un président qui est presque
barricadé on a un président qui est
protégé comme si ils avaient peur de ses
propres concitoyens
c'est une image pour moi qui est
terrible pour la présidence qui commence
et qui est malheureusement dommageable
pour le système américain
donc on est dans des circonstances
exceptionnelles puisqu'il y apporte des
nouveautés bien vous rompez on voit john
madden un actif à l'image un gérald
olivier on voit on voit joe biden je
veux parler vous couper c'est une c'est
une image très forte un évidement de de
cette cérémonie d'investiture joe biden
qui va également signé dix sept décrets
1 pour effacer la page
donald trump absolument et c'est dix
sept décrets sont très symbolique de la
volonté de faire un trait sur les quatre
années passées et je crains très fort
qu'il ya une contradiction entre la
volonté et non c'est de réconcilier
l'amérique et de célébrer une amérique à
nouveau unis mais de prendre des
décisions qui va qui vont à l'encontre
des souhaits des 75 millions d'électeurs
qui ont voté en faveur de donald trump
l'une de ces mesures consistera à
proposer la régularisation de 10 ou 15
millions d'émigrants clandestins aux
états unis et on sait que donald trump
avait fait de la lutte contre
l'immigration en particulier
l'immigration clandestine
l'un de ses chevaux de bataille donc
cette décision elle peut presque être
interprété comme une forme de
provocation vis-à-vis des électeurs de
donald trump pour moi ce n'est pas un
élément qui contribuera à la
réconciliation et à la réunification du
peuple américain sur la politique
internationale à quoi est-ce qu'il faut
s'attendre on a entendu un de part et
d'autre de nombreuses diplomatie salué
l'arrivée de joe biden ces prochaines
heures sur la scène internationale il va
se passer quoi selon vous gérald olivier
d'écouté il ya deux trois décisions qui
sont connus la première elle a été
évoquée par votre reportage
il va s'agir de réintégrer ou de rester
dans l'eau ms puisque donald trump avait
décidé d'en sortir
mais cette sortie était prévue pour
juillet 2021
donc elle va être annulé les états unis
vont rester au sein de cette
organisation internationale
la seconde ça va être de réintégrer
l'accord de paris sur le climat
là encore c'était un des éléments forts
de la présidente de donald trump qui
contestaient beaucoup des tests
contemporaine sur le réchauffement
climatique
et là on a une réintégration de joe
biden dans les décisions petit peu
multilatéral sur ce sujet et puis le
gros dossier qui était évoquée dans
votre reportage ça m dossier iranien
parce qu'en effet il y avait un accord
signé par obama
ce fameux jessy pi haut et qui était
supposé empêcher les
de parvenir à la bombe nucléaire et de
réintégrer une forme de concerts
économique des nations de latrobe est
sortie d'amérique d'accord il l'avait
dénoncée et il est fort probable que joe
biden relance des négociations pour
parvenir à une actualisation de cet
accord et puis le dossier à très long
terme évidemment c'est la chine
et là on est dans un petit incertain
parce que de par les affaires familiales
qui entourent joe biden on sait très
bien que son fils hunter a fait des
affaires avec la chine
du temps où son père était vice
président joe biden n'est pas forcément
le meilleur personnage pour prendre
avoir une position
je dirais extrêmement forte vis-à-vis de
la chine même si la présidence de donald
trump a changé la donne et à un petit
peu ou dans les yeux du reste du monde
sur la réalité de la stratégie chinoise
et je pense que joe biden aura une
attitude beaucoup plus ferme vis-à-vis
de chine jingping que celle qui avait
été celle de barack obama
il y a 6 ans ou plus merci gérald
olivier d'avoir répondu à nos questions